other than you know takes there's a lot
of kind of intuition but not a lot of
data behind it so i think that the idea
is that would all help support running
the plant more efficiently
to generate savings at a lot more of a
modest um cost saving and also the
meters i think would be recommended
under any option so even if we went with
one of the ghd options this
knowing where your waste is going would
be fundamental to them
as well
um so that was the case behind why we
think we
where we think we can spend money and
get a good benefit from it
in terms of the ini works which is
inflow and infiltration so essentially
um
uh stormwater
would
either flowing in
through
via
the surface or infiltrating through
underground into the wastewater network
um
as seen as another challenge for the
system and that can put pressure on the
plant downstream so we
we put a lot of loggers out in the
system to measure flows not just as it
comes into the plant but throughout the
network and um
we were fortunate to get a really big
storm as well straight after that so the
um the may and june floods happened a
little bit after we had the um meters
going and that allowed us to see where
the
inflow was coming into the system um
that provided pretty useful data um but
it didn't present us with any
opportunities to make really significant
savings as in investing you know modest
amount of money and getting a big gain
it was more
um
just incremental improvements um
as well as that work we also
did some property inspections which
again
offered some kind of um
not drastic problems but
a
reasonably large number of small issues
of um
that could
could be addressed through one-on-one
work with property owners but again it
would be incremental differences that
would make rather than wholesale changes
so there is a little bit more work to do
in the network but not um not work that
would
no big chunk of work that would make a
drastic difference so it's hard to
identify a particular project to do
there um it's probably more of an
ongoing investigation
um
and then further to that the other thing
i wanted to talk about briefly before
taking questions was the master plan
work so
um
we also are conscious that we've got a
resource consent for discharging waste
from the oxford wastewater treatment
plant coming up for renewal
in 2031
and um
with
uh changes that are happening we expect
that gaining a new consent will be more
challenging
we'll have more challenging conditions
to currently
um so we wanted to
have get an idea of what kind of changes
might we make at the plant
to make to meet that future new consent
conditions as well and start planning
for that now
um partly because it um
well it's good to to plan it out and
know what we've got coming and include
that in the next long-term plan but also
that we don't want to make any changes
at the plant now
that might be superseded or or become
redundant if we with a
whole different type of treatment system
so the master plan work is still uh
preliminary in nature it's um i've
attached a draft report for information
but we've
given quite a lot of feedback to the
consultant so far and it hasn't we
haven't got a final version of the
report yet so it's more just for
information at this stage on how
that project is progressing rather than
being in a position to make
recommendations or suggest particular
um
solutions
um but we so we intend after the
conclusion of that report to bring
a comprehensive um
you know finished report and recommend
options for
the longer term strategy for the
treatment plant but um i think the only
thing that is important to consider now
is that
the types of things that are suggested
there are still
you know the work we're proposing to do
to reduce the operational costs which
will have a benefit in the short term as
well as long term
will still be relevant for the longer
term
options as well of um
adding in new treatment processes so
that money won't become
you know wasted expenditure and it will
start saving money
sooner than you know that 10-year
horizon as well
so happy to take any questions on that
thanks colin caroline or
uh
do you want to add anything
all right so i've got a question from
council duty followed by council
meetings
and council stuart
all right are we right
i'm unmuted yep
colin just a query please
can you explain how that inflow system
is going to work once you've located
where the um
the excess water is coming from
just give us a
it's a little bit past my yeah um
technical knowledge
yeah so part of that is we um and this
was something i didn't talk about is
that we also looked at some benchmark
levels from what in new zealand or kind
of threshold levels on what is a
normal level of inflow and infiltration
for a wastewater scheme and where's the
kind of threshold where you should
where you've you know you're beyond an
acceptable level and you should um
be able to find areas to improve and in
general oxford was kind of on the cusp
of the
the you know the border of the upper
limit of acceptable versus the threshold
for doing more so it's kind of also
telling us that actually
the scheme isn't performing horrendously
and in fact when we compare it to
kaiapoi it performs better than kaiboy
for example because i um
so
that alongside the um
the other work we did with the loggers
and the private property inspections are
it's almost just telling us that there
is limited opportunities to really
cut that back drastically um
so it's more that we
we should monitor it closely and and if
we continue gathering this data we might
see it as it gets worse and be able to
target a solution but ultimately there's
not there doesn't appear to be
you know particular isolated spots where
there's just water gushing into the
system that's overloading the plant that
we could patch up and and make a big
dent in i think it's going to be more
through
targeting realigning and renewals sort
of gradually over time that will
um
you know keep it within an acceptable
level or bring it down gradually but
it's um
yeah it's it's not there's not one easy
project we can sell if we spend 50
thousand dollars here we'll have 20 less
flow at the plant or anything like that
it's just going to be um
i think the loggers and things we've got
will just help us target future annuals
and that kind of thing
that's my uh next question i want to ask
please is that
um
where they those ear vents
um
just down our drive uh when it rains
that it covers right over those events
so would that be creating water problems
uh yes that's the kind
yep that's exactly the kind of thing we
are looking at through the private
property inspection so there was
um i can't remember the number but
something like 100 properties had um
gully traps i think under the building
code are meant to have 100 millimeters
of
sort of riser around them so that if um
the flooding would around the house
would need to be more than 100
millimeters deep
to um to get into the sewer system and
we've overlaid or we targeted those
inspections with our flood model to try
to look at where there is flooding um
so we've we're going to go through that
with our wastewater engineer and um send
letters to people with things like what
you've got so hopefully we picked you up
in our survey i'm not sure if anyone
came onto your property to do a
inspection but um people you know with
that kind of thing where the
um
there's no riser around the gully trap
will um and they're in an area that
could have some flooding will intend to
send a letter to ask them to put a riser
on it which is quite a basic little job
but um
each one of them will make
a small improvement to the um to what's
coming to the treatment plant
thank you um i think you probably need
to come and have a look
okay
thanks
thanks
and just further
collins response um councillor duty just
for your information there are a number
of
stormwater projects that are looking at
addressing some of that flooding so
upstream of tawera lane there's the york
street diversion works which will
actually look at cutting off some of
that catchment and we've also got
investigations underway in the um
burnett
street area and high street area of
oxford so that's actually looking at
improving the drainage system such that
um
there's less flooding that is going to
inundate the wastewater system
okay um i've got uh council meetings
hi guys um hey great reports there's um
an awful lot of information in there and
it's quite thorough but i just probably
further to what um council of duty's
just asked um just can you help me
understand like if the ini level at
oxford due to rainfall is so much lower
than say kaya poi and is at the normal
threshold values for typical new zealand
wastewater
systems
then um why is it that during the last
flood event
um back in may that oxford had restrict
water use due to excess
water in the ponds during that event and
kaiapoi didn't
um i don't really sort of
get the connection between
um
not having as much rainfall and then
this rainfall event causing the
wastewater treatment to
have a bit of a crisis there
yeah um i think it's hard to
i might not have explained it pretty
well it's it's not that oxford is right
on the
good level of ini it's at the cusp of
the the complete upper limit of good
versus you um so it's sort of at the
threshold between whether you'd call it
except you know the upper limit of
acceptable or the lower limit of
unacceptable so it does have
um i and i
problems it's just that
um then they're not um
they're not so bad that there's these
really easy things that can be solved
it's more this um there's probably like
a thousand little weak joints that have
um you know
that allow a little bit of ground water
to seep in rather than something that
can
easily be be solved so it's it's not a
really good system but it's not a really
poor system um
as well and i think
um one of the things with the treatment
plant is um
we're constrained a little bit by and
caroline might be able to help me with
this question but we could pump more
water through the um
the treatment process during a flood but
that risks washing out
um and
and making the treatment system worse so
the pumps have
been set to a certain limit and then
what what they can't pump away
goes into the holding pond and if um if
the inflow um into the plant
minus what's pumped through the
treatment system exceeds what the pond
can handle the pond is at risk of
overflowing so
it's that's probably relevant from a
couple of points of view that was a
really extreme event i think for the
catchment it was um in the order of 150
year or 100 year type thing so it's not
a normal event
i realized that that was quite
quite a huge um rainfall event but um is
it just because the capacity of the at
the oxford wastewater treatment plant is
so much
smaller than that at kaiapoi that
expects that
effect
maybe i can add to that so oxford's got
a mechanical treatment plant whereas the
rest of the district like in the eastern
district we've got porn systems so
basically that's just a better buffer
for any fluctuations in flow so oxford
being a mechanical plant is quite
compact and it's very sensitive to
um flow fluctuations so we have got the
um holding tank that will buffer storm
flows up to a certain
capacity but
beyond that then we will have issues
with the treatment plant
functioning well
so that's different in that aspect
thank you
council stuart
thank you
i sent a question through to kelly this
morning um
and i apologize colin i didn't and
caroline i didn't actually think of
sending it to you but it concerns um
going forward in the future and i noted
in the report
um from one of the consultants i don't
know which one it is but um
that the current plant produces um
a an effluent with a nitrogen loading
rate of 140 kg per hectare per year
which is in within the current um
consent um which is 200
kilograms per hectare per year
but in fact my question concerns the nps
fresh water which
gave a limit for inputs um
onto ground for irrigation or fertilizer
which effectively this is doing to the
um of 120 kg per hectare
uh per year as a maximum under the nps
last year which and none of this is
referred to um by the consultants when
it's talking about planning for the um
plant going forward so there's so
there's that question which is where is
the requirements that it will be across
all discharges um
uh to meet the nps and the other thing
is when they do the calculations um to
show what um after you've sprayed this
out onto the the land uh there's a
calculation there which i don't know how
they get it but it's um
how much is used up by the pasture and
how much actually goes to the root zone
um
and i uh the question is
what mechanism what formula are they
using for calculating this
if they're using overseer which they may
be
as everybody is doing in the regulatory
space and it is now seen to be not fit
for purpose
your question is counselor stuart well
there's two of them what are they using
and how good is this report going
forward when in fact
it it talks about proposed stuff for the
for pc7 which is past being proposed we
will have to revisit all this when we
get the thing out so
what what are the parameters here and
how how robust is this plant going to be
when you overlay
the nps fresh water requirements
yeah i think those are all very good
points that you've raised they have you
i presume you got as far through the um
ghd report as appendix b which sets out
how they've come up with
what they think the um
the future nitrate
limit would be
but um
i can see they haven't it hasn't
addressed every point you've made just
now so um i think we will have to just
um it's really good to get that feedback
especially when the report is still in
draft state and just work through that
with them
a little bit more to make sure we've
covered all that off um
uh yeah
sorry
we are we are hampered in that while um
well ecan has got the decision on pc7 it
hasn't actually been released to the
public
so
they are um in the dark somewhat so
they've worked from the proposed
limits
that were in the in the
draft a plan change
and that's going to be superseded in a
matter of weeks perhaps by um what comes
out when
when ecan looks at the overseer
constraints and therefore um the
validity of the decisions from the
commissioners you're getting into a
debating point here no no i'm just
asking a question about
is this is this in the mix here and so
what value is this report when the whole
environment has changed
has already changed which isn't
mentioned in this and will continue to
change i need you to confine it to a
question because we will be here all the
time
okay so colin yeah so i think the short
answer is that we will um
make sure as much information as is
available to the consultant is is taken
into account in the final report and
it's also worth noting that it's uh um
[Music]
the consent doesn't
require renewal for 10 years so we need
to but we should be setting aside a
budget now which will do and if we need
to tweak exactly what that solution is
as you know we get more clarity we'll
also we'll have time to adjust that
before we come to constructing something
as well but um yeah yeah so i think it
we will
um we will be able to consider as much
as as possible and make sure none of
those points you've raised and missed um
but also we won't be rushing into
building something that'll become
redundant either because there will be a
bit of time before we start construction
thank you thanks colin uh thanks sandra
um council redmond
ah thank you colin i see that sludge is
a byproduct of the whole process and
very important
on page 50 and 51
you refer to the henley sludge age
controller
is the purchase of that still on the
table it seems like an opportunity we
shouldn't miss
yes we need to um
kick off conversations with uh city
council again which our previous
wastewater manager had
started um but
yeah that's one thing we thought is that
the the operational changes alone could
provide the best
outcome because although that um
unit that had been discussed us buying
it for a nominal one dollar
um it would still cost a bit of money to
install and get operational and it was
also suggested to do some pilot trials
before committing to it so
what we could do is um
in parallel with the operational
improvements then look at
packing up those conversations with the
city council again
and probably doing some kind of
condition assessment of it and it might
be that we could if we thought it was um
an opportunity we might miss
then we could
buy it almost as a backup because it um
or we could um you know we wouldn't have
to start using it straight away if we
had
if we um could buy it and store it
somewhere or we might um
you know we might not need it if the
operational improvements work really
well the mpv has shown that actually
they could provide the best solution
without that so um
yeah it is something that we can
continue to explore
with or without the other
um changes we're proposing
thank you
thank you uh council blackie
thank you you saw i support councillor
edmunds thing about this machine
although when i read it as a henley uh
sludge age controller i was a bit
worried it was a device to get rid of
old age pensioners but
for a one dollar by all means grab it
and have it up our sleeve my question is
um well the options down down the track
um one of them conveyancing this a lot
to ring aura can you explain to me the
difference he says the gravity main
could be installed with manholes every
120 meters why do we need those every
120 meters and then it says or combine
it with a pressure falling main which
uses the natural hydraulic grade as the
driving force so what's the difference
between a pressure falling made main
using the grade as the force in an
ordinary gravity main
there's very little difference really i
think it's
usually gravity mains have um a manhole
every 130 meters and that's what a coda
practice says they should have um and
that's because in a conventional gravity
system you've got houses connecting
you know all along it and and you could
get blockages and you need manholes to
get in and inspect and clear blockages
so
i think it was more just them saying
well we could have designed it by your
code of practice but in this case it
doesn't make sense because it's just a
big giant long pipe that has you know
basically no connections along the route
so
i think um
that was their logic and just justifying
why they hadn't allowed for that mini
manholes which would have made the cost
even higher um
uh caroline can chip in if i've got that
wrong but i think that's all it was and
it was just really a quite a broad
exercise just to demonstrate we've been
looked at and check whether it stacked
up at all against treatment improvements
because um
we thought if we start proposing
spending
a few million dollars at oxford so the
question will get asked well hang on a
minute why don't we just
pipe it all to to rank your like all
their other schemes um so we wanted to
make sure we'd at least looked at it but
even with that kind of
lower cost design it still didn't look
like it would stick up
okay councillor atkinson followed by
council award
evil did you want to ask a question yep
you're back on mute
excuse me um
just just around that exact point
where
in the dollar scheme
does it become
um that we need to
uh i'll use the word scrap this plant
that's not exactly what i mean but um
downgrade this plant and actually get it
into the east and eastern districts
where is that point
um we're spending a lot of money here
we've spent a lot of money in the past
there is clearly going to be upgrades
that are going to come and under the new
three waters they could be quite
extensive
where is the point
where we actually do come to rangera
with the pipeline where's the
investigation i realize you've done a
basic one but where's the investigation
and the price point that we do that
i think um
i mean essentially i think our thoughts
were this is enough to justify not doing
it 20 million versus 3 million is a huge
difference and it doesn't it still
doesn't take into account the um
that all that waste would then have to
flow through the ring euro system so
there would have to be some you know
there'd be some knock-on effects there
where it would consume capacity within
range euro then it's got to flow through
the ring euro plant onto kaiapoi and
consumer capacity there so there's
there's more costs or you know indirect
costs in terms of consuming capacity
beyond that 20 million as well so
i think
i don't think there is a case even you
know even if our three million dollars
in the future became five or six because
we you know we want to achieve better
environmental outcomes or something i
think i don't think it it's going to get
anywhere near becoming a viable option
based on the high level analysis
okay thank you
because award
um thank you um
i'm just if you can help me um why would
we um
pipe and lose all that excess water out
to sea
when we can recycle it in a sustainable
way and retain it
with the
locally
into into what might be a drought area
and
be able to um keep the moisture in the
ground um
i really don't see the point and sending
it all out to sea
yeah i think jared was going to answer
that
you're on mute yep
so i'm just
having trouble finding my button with my
mouse okay um look
that's a good question to ask and it is
something that does come up um
as a general question and
um
and it's good that you've raised it
specifically in this instance because we
do have a plant here that's quite a long
way away from the sea um but
in um
[Music]
in in countries where there is a
a lot more scarcity of water than we
have in waimakariri that's exactly what
they do um
and
um even
it's even done in the north island um to
some extent hamilton discharges its
wastewater into the waikato river and
then auckland picks it up further on
down the river treats it and drinks it
um
so that happens all over the world
and there are
there's certainly a lot of
consideration now
to trying to reduce the water
consumption um
and the amount of water you're disposing
of
and treating as a waste in all sorts of
areas so the very easiest level is
making sure you try and retain the
stormwater for example um
as a starting point
the um we are very fortunate where we
are in waimakariri that we've actually
got an abundance compared to other areas
of
good potable groundwater that doesn't
actually require any treatment um
so while we
and i don't know the exact figures
probably kelly wouldn't know these
better than me but the actual proportion
of the water that is used in our
district is something in the order of i
think it's either one or four percent
for um
of all of the water so most of the water
is actually used for agriculture for
irrigation um
and uh
where um
and it's very expensive to treat
wastewater to a point where you can
um use it to drink and then put it back
into the potable system so
from in our context we're a very long
way away from anything that would stack
up in terms of full recycling um
at least at oxford we do actually use
the um
waste water
for land disposal
and that presents challenges because of
other issues that councillor stewart was
is talking about in terms of having an
impact on water quality um but yeah
really good point um we're quite a long
way away from that being a
realistic option for our district but
over time um that question will probably
continue to be asked and you'll see more
and more being adopted in other places
as well
well thank you for that um i really i
had a look with councillor williams down
at um no no that's it's a debating point
unless it's a question council award
is it a question
um
you raise it in debate
yes yes
thank you counselor duty did you have
another question
and then followed by council williams
thank you um just i just would like a
little bit concerned about perhaps what
the
figures in that might escalate to what
um
this this
service is going to cost the rate payer
and i just would
like our staff if they would please
consider at some stage just to keep our
weight powers up to date on what's going
on and what's happening because
um
this could be quite a shock to them if
it gets out of hand of it
so
especially with at the moment with what
you're going to be doing with our
stimulus funding it would be very
helpful for them to understand
the reason behind it
your thoughts colin yes yeah definitely
we can do
some comms around
the
you know the outcome of the project when
we're finished to say this we allocate
this money and these this is what we've
achieved with it and hopefully um
have some positive outcomes from the
their trials in terms of the optimizing
the operational costs um
so i think that'll be some good news and
then it'll also be
um come with a little bit of what might
be seen as bad news that coming up at
the end of the decade we're going to
have to spend some more money um on the
consent as well but um
yeah so but definitely we we will do
some comments when this all concludes
thank you thank you mr mural
just hold on this cancer war but you're
account not council award councillor
williams you're indicating you wish to
move is that right yep
uh
sorry well counselor duty is indicating
she wants to move you wish to second
counsel williams is that right did you
have a question as well council williams
no
so um
is there any other questions
so we'll come to the recommendation uh
council duties moving seconded by
council williams do you wish to speak
counsel duty
no thanks i just would like to say thank
you very much for the report it's a very
good report and um
helping us to understand
just what this waste water treatment
plant is achieving and what we need to
be doing in the future so thank you very
much colin and
kelly thank you
thank you councillor williams
yes no thanks um colin and um caroline
and kelly um you're very good report um
i can see but it makes sense to um
to do this it's a
short term and long term savings so um
that's something's going to have to be
done anyway so um
um it's a sector you couldn't still
eventually start by helping and reducing
the cost for the office of residents so
it's pretty good thank you thank you
just um colleagues if you can use the
reaction button
counselor duty if you just unraise your
hand now
but i noticed some of you were doing it
what it does and even during speaking
time uh it just lets me know and then it
keep pops you up to the top of the
screen so um if you can use the raise to
your hand raise hand function and after
you finish speaking your answer your
question take it down it just assists me
with um
knowing that i've got you there for
speaking or wave your hand but if you
could use that function it'd be helpful
okay i had counselor stuart
thank you
certainly support
this work that's outlined here
what i did find astonishing
was the inflow from groundwater when the
plant was not under
stress from
any
rain
it has a huge amount of groundwater
that's getting into the system which i
find absolutely extraordinary
and
but what i'm concerned about as i
indicated earlier
is that
going forward with this plant um i do
take on board what councillor atkinson
said that we keep
we keep front and center um
the comparison with joining up to a
larger plant somewhere in the in the
forefront of our minds because i'm very
well aware of what happened to um
somehow water supply when we we went um
pretty much alone for a long time and
then suddenly um
and there was a proliferation of of
private wells all around the district
where um
where
um
subdivisions were happening and lo and
behold it turned out that it now
only a few years later it would have
been much more cost efficient and also
more
um
well
taking the well-being of the um of our
population into account that they had
all joined together so i would like to
see that that is kept um to the
forefront of all considerations with
this plant which to my mind still
remains pretty much
a dog but what what is coming in the 10
years when um will be increased
standards um through nps's and plan
changes that we don't seem to actually
have in the draft reports that are there
and i'm really well aware that this this
discharge will be considered just like a
a fertilizer a dairy farm fertilizing
ground which effectively it does do
and it's already exceeding the cap
that's been put on by the government
at this point well it doesn't need to
worry about it because it's got a
consent up to 2031
but that's not going to go
it's going to go downwards
in that 10 years and i would like to
make
be assured that um
that
the um
exactly what it's going to cost to keep
us within
limits that are going to be outlined by
plan changes in national policy
statements but
in the in the interim
i'm quite i'm relatively comfortable
with them
with what's proposed
thank you
i thank you i'm going to support the
recommendations this has been a
long-standing issue in
oxford i remember when i was a counselor
out there myself when it was
raised and
certainly some of the early public
meetings i attended where the community
were promised all sorts of things that
would have happened with this
treatment plan i think um council
stewards have act
uh and in her terminology of what the
system actually is
we've spent a lot of money
patching it over the years this is just
another
part of that exercise so it says
something we need to keep an eye on and
i agree with council duty we do need to
keep our community informed out there
because
something they well understand given
what they were promised
to what they were delivered so
it pre it precedes all of us this
particular plant
but it's our responsibility so this is
another part of that journey to um
making sure that it's delivering what it
should be delivering so
i'm going to support the recommendation
i agree with other comments i think
staff have done an excellent job on
these summaries any further speakers
write a reply counselor duty
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye just raise your
hands
uh yep good that's well and truly uh
against uh let's carry it
thanks uh colin
caroline
kelly and jared
so um we come to
uh next is the it was to be an adverse
weather event recovery report that's not
going to happen today and in fact that
won't be happening
on our agendas going forward thanks
caroline
uh but there will be an update that
comes by way of report to our next
meeting of council
and it wasn't ready for today so that's
why it didn't come
here
so
on that we do come to 7.2 though um so
it's a flood event emergency work
update and that's a report in the name
of jared stewart still yes you are sorry
jared yes uh thank you thank you i'm
looking i've also got um
kelly and colin and um
joanne uh hopefully um
here to just help with any questions
that come out
i see simon's joined i see simon's
joined
simon as well great so look um you will
recall
we brought a report to you in july and
effectively in july
we were asking uh permission um in some
what a retrospective manner to spend 3.5
million dollars
and we actually went to a fair level of
detail in that report describing the
um extent of the damage from the flood
um
and
where that was going um so we had the
opportunity now to finish a lot of that
work
um with
and to have a much closer look at
whether we can manage it within existing
budgets uh whether there's any other
funding sources
including uh co-funding from wakakotahi
uh any possibilities of insurance
um and just having you know generally
having a much better understanding so
this report actually um
uh that 3.5 million has now been reduced
to
2.82 million as a request
and we've also
got a much more clear definition of
exactly which areas we need to take that
from which budgets
and so this is actually asking for your
approval uh for those budgets that that
are listed in recommendation b
um
and specifically the road and green
spaces and property
so we don't actually request any
additional budget for uh the three
waters
um as as a result of the work that we've
been doing um it is probably also just
worth commenting that with this is
really about the um response and
recovery from the flood event um as with
any of this this any event like this we
identify
um areas
around the district where we've got
issues um and they often only come to
light in events like this um and so this
doesn't
this report doesn't cover
everything that may come in the future
um
as a result of those issues being
identified so sometimes they were known
issues to us and this has just um once
again reminded us that we've got a some
kind of a deficiency in our
infrastructure or our roading network um
and there have been some that have
actually come to light here but they
they um we're not asking for any money
for those um and we still have a whole
series of service requests we're working
through so some of those may eventually
um come up as either a report to
utilities and roading um as
investigations um are carried out
or um and possibly eventually in future
bits and annual plans and the long term
plan so um that's just sort of a bit of
an overview for me i don't i don't think
i need to talk very much to the report i
think you're probably um
familiar with most of it and just happy
to
take any questions thank you thank you
i've got firstly councillor williams
followed by councillor barnes
thanks jared
yep thanks jared um
this report um is it possible to get a
um and added on to it so we actually
know the actual total cost of the um
that flood possibly region um you know
the water and wastewater and drainage
costs um i know they're coming out of
existing budgets but it'd be
quite interesting to find out what the
actual total cost that flood possibly
read them
[Music]
yes that is possible um
uh yep yep so the but not right now but
we could um circulate a memo to
councillors with an updated table with
our best estimate of that figure is
happy to do that perhaps that could come
in simon's
coming report uh that's to do an overall
on the recovery maybe simon you could
include a table in there with the total
cost if you could
thank you
okay with you council williams
uh council abana
so just to clarify we've basically
received no government funding to assist
us with the lees valley road damages at
this stage could you clarify that
um i'll clarify it and if joanne needs
to add anything we have received well we
um
we're expecting to get the waka katahi
um
funding so
the the figure that we've got in there
um
if we don't get that we'll let you know
but i'll be extremely surprised if we
don't get that um if that's to does that
answer your question
partially but there was no additional
except for the
the general normal subsidy that we
received from waka kotahi is that
correct
no additional funding for that correct
that is correct although it's um it is
unbudgeted from their perspective as
well so they um it is additional over
there um funding that we had budgeted
but it but it is at the same level i
suppose um
and there's no yeah there's certainly
there's no not where we're not aware of
any other funding source um from a
separate
entity or anything thanks for clarifying
that jared just making sure we can get
money from all sources
the
last question i've got slightly
operational so joanne might be able to
answer this one
we know the ford's going to be opening
because i noticed that rural residents
are ignoring the closed signs because
the fords are at such a low level in
several areas particularly the earlies
road downs road one
so just um to provide a clarification on
the funding so we get the
nzta 51
funding rate for the 10
above
our normal maintenance operations
renewals budget which does mean that
there is a small portion of the
emergency works claim which we are
likely to get 71
or funding at um
assistance rate on so we are just
working through um
that with nzta at the moment but there
will be hopefully a little bit that we
can get an enhanced fire on
in terms of the forwards so we've just
been working with ecan on the fords on
the air river and we've had
i guess some issues with those because
of the amount of sediment that's been
dropped into the rivers at each of the
fords so
we have kept the fords closed until
previously because the river levels have
just been a bit high
but acknowledging they are dropping now
um
and
sorry it can't have been dropped working
down the river moving the material
within the riverbed and we've been
working with them to try and tie in the
fords as we go through so
that is something we will be looking to
try and get them open um within the next
few weeks
so how will that be communicated to
residents because obviously some fords
are used more than others and are
actually major at almost major routes in
the rural sense um particularly like
like the ones closer to the eastern side
of the district
yep i think we keep a list of fords that
are closed and open on our website so we
can i can certainly get that updated and
can work with the comms team when we are
opening them to get that message out
thank you
thank you um just if refer to pages 188
and 189 of the agenda
it's gotten here the
the total cost notwithstanding the
question accounts of williams raise but
assuming we get recovery then the cost
to the actual cost to the district's 1.2
million
am i sh am i reading that table
correctly jared
yeah
yes
although that doesn't necessarily
include all the costs that council of
williams is looking yeah so that's why i
said notwithstanding is yes it's about
one point about one notwithstanding that
but the cost to the districts 1.2 yup
okay
or assuming we get all the other funding
in place any other questions
okay so we've got a recommendation
someone prepared to move moved by
council awards seconded by councillor
barnett do you wish to speak council
award
just to say that um uh
well done uh tremendous effort to get
everything repaired and in a timely
fashion and it was huge huge effort and
um the report was very detailed it was
really good and um
i just think that the team have done an
amazing job of getting everything back
up and running and insecure as quick as
they can so well done everybody
that's about it yes just to emphasize
that also i thought the recovery if it
was very very good in a very extreme
rainfall event um
and people did feel well supported there
was good communication going forward i
think now though we don't want to drop
the ball and not look at things that we
can do to improve going forward um and
the recovery on a rural perspective has
been a little bit slow with some of the
issues such as roading forwards and so
on and there's been little communication
back to residents when some of those
issues
may not be seen by the city dwellers but
are quite important out here in the
country so i just would like to see
perhaps a little bit of upped
communications about what our plans are
now as we're recovering and also then
perhaps really looking forward to that
debrief when we can actually talk about
how we can stop these some of these
things happening in the future some of
the minor issues um that rear up every
single time we have a rain event
thank you i've got uh councillor uh was
it williams i think yeah and council
followed by council duty who i've lost
on the screen council williams
yes thanks um councillor barnett just
sort of raised the wee bit point and my
point was um we were going to have a
debrief on this um storm event and we
actually haven't had this proper debrief
yet so i just wondering when that's
being penciled in
it's a good question jared i wonder if
you could um take that one up it should
have been scheduled um
a debrief on this particular event
because i i have asked
for that to be done so i'm wondering if
jared you wouldn't mind taking the lead
on that and making sure it's included in
one of our briefings at some point
yes yes that's no no problem at all
thank you
all right counselor duty did you yes
please i'd just like to say thank you
very much to the staff for all the work
they've done particularly the amount of
work that was done up in lee's valley
gratefully appreciated that was a
mammoth job to do and
and to be able to have that road working
again now is
wonderful for the community that uses it
so thank you
okay um
any other speakers just totally endorsed
the comments that have been made an
outstanding effort by our staff and
particularly the response to lee's
valley that was a huge challenge in
there
i'm just wondering jared just timing of
that debrief if we could have it
probably before we um discuss um simon's
report so even if we timed it
um
even if we took a time start of midday
before the count next council meeting
before simon's
report comes to us that we give time to
have an opportunity to feed that in and
and have that fresh in our mind as we
come to simon's report might be a good
way of handling that
um councillor edmund
uh thank you mr mayor uh just i'm in
support of the
excuse me recommendation it's an example
of how local knowledge is very helpful
in times of emergency
so um it's a good report and a good
response and i think part of that
success is
the staff local knowledge local contacts
thank you
sounds like a good argument for keeping
the three waters councillor redmond
okay
i never mentioned that mr mayor
any further any further speakers
write a reply to the mover
because the war do you wish to say
anything no i'll put the recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carried excellent
thanks jared
and thanks for representing us on the
conversation that i can't be at shortly
because or could nominate someone else
to be at because we're at a council
meeting so thank you for your work there
this afternoon
you and jeff i think jeff is uh going
there as well
all right so we move now to
uh other reports 8.1 which is the
canterbury waste joint committee um
have we got kitty coming in
yes
i had jared just while waiting for kitty
to come in they had predicted not so
great weather so i'm not sure where it's
gone but it's a beautiful day out here
today so
is there is that weather prediction yeah
we're
we are watching the weather um
what
uh we're not necessarily too much
worried about rain in this part of the
district down the rangory end um but it
is possible with this sort of nor west
cycle that we could get a compounding
series of events
and the alps that bring up the
waimakariri river
so we're just keeping an eye on that uh
along with the environment canterbury
river engineers um
and possibly to a lesser extent if some
of that spilled into the lees valley or
um
in the cuckoo river but that's that's
even less likely but yeah we're just
keeping keeping an eye on it but yeah we
can expect it to be windy in a bit
we've got some terrible wind up here mr
mayor
already okay
and obviously wendy's got the same so um
thank you jared for that update um
uh kitty uh your report 8.1 pages
209-229
thanks kitty
um before i present my report i'd just
like to clarify a couple of points that
aren't quite clear
environment canterbury doesn't receive
any of the waste levy so any funding
they provide would have to be from rates
and they also don't provide any waste
services and don't need to develop a
waste management plan under the waste
the waste minimization act
they do have responsibility however for
contaminated land hazardous waste
management and also managing litter
within river boundaries
so
there would be benefit to them
to being part of the canterbury waste
joint committee and work with staff
to
look at waste as a whole which includes
the contaminated land and hazardous
waste management
so my report gives some background to
the formation of the canterbury waste
joint committee which was formed in 2006
and at that point comprised all local
authorities in the canterbury region
plus environment canterbury
ecan provided 25 of the funding at the
city funded 50 and the other council's
funding was based proportionately on
prop population
the total funding pool was 150 000
and the ecan share was 37 500.
when he can withdrew from the joint
committee in 2011 the total funding pool
was dropped to 112 000
dollars and the ratios were adjusted for
council population changes
since then ecan staff have continued to
actively participate in the staff group
meetings
and they've led some projects
and more recently we've been discussing
the need for a dedicated staff resource
who would be able to lead regional
collaboration activities oversee
projects the
canterbury waste joint committee fund
and report on their progress
and also investigate regional
opportunities for investment for example
into waste division infrastructure
in order to leverage regional funding
and seek national funding from the waste
minimisation fund
the report to the joint committee was
prepared on the basis that ecan would
accept the proposal to rejoin the
committee
and to accommodate the staff position
with other councils funding the staff's
salary
the ecan funding would therefore be
around about forty thousand dollars
which is of the same orders as the
previous funding levels
um in order for the committee chair to
start the conversation with environment
canterbury
um all councils party to the
constituting agreement have to support
the recommendation by the joint
committee which is to agree to a new
staff position
being created
agree to increasing the budget to fund
that salary
and agree to invite ekan to rejoin the
committee and implied in that is to host
the staff position
um page 213 of the agenda 4.5 outlines
the benefits to all councils from the
staff position
um and note that if he can were to draw
rejoin and host the staff position we do
have enough budget in the long term plan
for the increased call on funding
i'm happy to take questions
thank you um thanks kelly any questions
of kitty
some of uh council duty
followed by council brian
just a week question kitty uh why
why would the staff be um
placed in
environment canterbury when it could be
in the council christchurch city council
it was thought given that
it has a regional focus the regional
council is the best place for that staff
position
previously with the hazardous waste
committee that we had
back when i first started that was
hosted by environment canterbury and and
run through them
so it was seen as a really good um
a fit i suppose regionally rather than
if they were in christchurch city then
they may get substituted into what
christchurch needs
councillor i'm brian yeah i spend the
county i'd like to move when you be
ready okay thank you uh councillor
blackie
yeah
just briefly kitty um so okay so so the
the position and the money are subject
to it to um he can coming back in
and i i'm kind of amazed that that the
the what the waste joint committee after
how many decades of of progress and and
um
and being there at this stage have to
agree that you need a new staff position
to progress to progress waste
minimization what is going to happen to
that to the situation forget the money
what's going to happen to this whole
waste minimisation concept if he can
don't come back in
that that is a very good question um and
that would have to go back to the
committee to consider in the staff
report
and the fallback position could be that
christchurch city council hosts
that
staff position
but that that again that would have to
go back through
the staff group to report back to the
joint committee who would then make
recommendations to council
okay further questions so i have got an
indicated mover and counts the brine
seconded by
uh councillor barnett
council brian do you wish to speak
thanks mr mayor um most of you have
heard me talking about how we need to
take a more regional approach uh with
regard to waste minimisation and you've
heard me speak about the opportunities
that are available not only with the
levy money that comes into into
canterbury councils but also the levy
money that is held by government for for
bigger projects
we need somebody to be looking at the
opportunities for these bigger projects
and somebody who can can work it and
it's tough to to say that the staff
group uh should be able to manage that
so i see this as a real opportunity and
an answer to councillor blacky's
question
we don't know what the governance team
or the the governors of ecans viewer
obviously staff are interested but it'll
come down to a meeting such as this by
by ecan
to make a decision whether they want to
do it if if and i hope this doesn't
happen if they decide that no this isn't
for us and we don't want to to to do it
at the end of the day i'm picking
because of the importance of of a
regional approach
it would be unfair to put another 40 000
impost on on the city
and we may end up bringing something
similar to this back at a future council
meeting i certainly don't want to let
this let this drop uh if he can
unfortunately if they were if they said
no i would not like to see this drop so
i hope all colleagues support it you've
heard my views on it before and it's a
very good report thank you very much
kitty
thank you seconder
you absolutely agree with everything
that council o'brien has said um if we
don't get ecan in the room and around
that table i don't think a regional
initiative will succeed because there's
so many parts to waste and waste
minimisation and they are an essential
part of that our staff are already
incredibly busy uh with the initiatives
they have and it's
having the an actual dedicated resource
to look on a regional basis
is essential if we're going to make any
progress
in the right in waste minimisation
realistically and our community have
been asking for it we're getting more
and more people wanting to do the right
thing and we've got to enable facilities
and operations that are going to cater
to that growing need in our community
excellent
further speakers
council
meetings just like to endorse that
position as well that it makes sense to
me that our regional council looks after
a regional issue and if you really look
at everybody who who's
sitting in the membership of the working
committee
that
those are all basically
councils that feed into cape valley as
an example so it's actually it behooves
all of us
to work together to reduce
our waste for for many reasons not the
least of which that um
you know let's let's prolong the asset
that we've got
and it's obviously the better thing all
around for the environment anyway and
having somebody that can actually take a
broader view of that makes sense to me
so i'm in support of the recommendation
i'm going to support the recommendation
as well but i just uh and support the
comments that have been made but i just
particularly want to acknowledge um
council brian and thank you for your
work and expertise in this area and
keeping us
up to date uh with where things are
going so thanks robbie for all that you
do in this area it's appreciated
you fear the
speakers um
council brian sorry sandra is that you
wanting to speak or is it just a thumbs
up okay uh write a reply counselor
just a slight correction council
meanings they're not not all these ones
are worthless on cape valley so you've
got tamaroo and mckenzie they're not so
yeah thanks
okay i'll put the recommendation all
those in favor please say aye
contrary
to clear that carried
thanks kitty uh and by the way kitty
thanks um i know you and the team are
doing a lot through covert um
keeping the waste stream going and
making sure that we
have uh combined messaging across
council so we don't get into that stupid
situation that happened last time
um with which cost us all a lot of money
so
i know that puts the team under a lot of
pressure down their transfer stations
but um
like many of us i'm sure we'll be down
to had a good clear out through this
period so i know that it's uh there's a
steady stream coming through so thanks
for what you're doing to keeping it
managed for us thank you very much
okay
so we're now coming to 8.2 which is um
the walking and cycling network plan so
i think don's joining us for this
don y i see don wise and ellie mace
cochran's joined so
and kieran
so just allow those
come through hi ellie
hi dan
um
we've got
is
it you that's leading this report ellie
or is don
um
[Music]
okay i see don's there so
coming in so just wait for him to
connect to audio
we're kieran as well
right hi guys i'm i'm
it's good to see you i
see you on the footpath occasionally
going for a run pass so it's good to see
you um don
alright so um ellie
hi everyone so the purpose of this
report is to provide an update to
council on feedback received from the
community boards and also seeks approval
to consult on the walkman cycling
network plan and associated
infrastructure prioritization program
the report included in the attachments
was taken to each of the community
boards last night last month we received
feedback from the oxford hoca and wooden
slifton community boards during their
meetings and this has been detailed in
this updated report
the recommended option is to approve
consultation on all of the proposed
routes and prioritizations as this will
enable engagement with both the public
and key stakeholders to get their
opinions on the proposed plan um john if
you've got anything to add
don did you have anything you wish to
add to the report
um i'm hearing two voices
one can't help you with the second one
can help you with the first
[Laughter]
i can might need it oh sorry i'm not
going to say anything further because
it's going to get me in trouble
did you wish to add anything don you
okay
no i i have nothing further to add um
ali's gonna
can anybody hear me yup
yes yes
yes we can
all right well it sounds like the
audio's playing up there for dom so um
so questions i've got councilor barnett
um
no i'm not muted sorry
um
i'm a bit confused by this report guys
because
in the report below you have got
feedback from the ring your ashley
community board but in this report you
haven't
and the map you've got is the old map
that you consulted with the boards but
the funding which is on
so i'm working two computers this is on
page 264
of the agenda if you look at 264
that reflects the changes that
we made in ranger ashley community board
as far as i'm concerned but the two
reports don't match up and i'm wondering
what are we passing today
ah so
you're okay you're not hearing two of us
now don
yes i still am i'm still hearing um
kirsten speaking as well but anyway
the answer is that uh it may have been
the approach that i requested that we
put a covering report over the top of
the original reports that went to the
boards so the book the covering report
to the council
is the requested
for you to pass
so where is the map that accompanies
that recommendation don because some of
those items were taken out of the map
in terms of the prioritization
my understanding was we were going to
remove some of the things out of there
after the community board feedback
um yes so the maps that are shown are
not the prioritization maps are the
overall network plan maps
um we removed the prioritization maps
just because it was getting too
confusing we've put the prioritizations
in a table
so what's going out to the community
because i'd like to see that before i
move it for consultation
well
is there a way that that the
correct map can be emailed through
otherwise mr mayor i'd like to move a
procedural motion that this lays on the
table for one month well just hold on um
before we do that i think i think if we
can we just
how how soon could you email us a copy
of the correct map
um
probably today tomorrow
well
it'll
no in the next five minutes ellie yeah i
think so otherwise it'll be laying on
the table
maybe if we could just um move to the
next item
and then we could come back to this uh
don you're leading this so while you're
doing that ellie if you could
and i'm happy to then call a pause and
we can just consider uh that at that
point so
if you can get that to um
ellie have you got all our email
addresses or the councillor's email
address oh yeah i can find them yeah
okay all right i'll just confirm for the
maps you're after the prioritization
maps
they're the ones that council barnard
asked which are the correct ones that
have come following the ones that match
the funding prioritization on
page 264
yeah property one two three
as the where we're going to spend the
money
rather than the network map
okay let's
and what we might do i think ellie is um
we might do a share screen and go
through it together so i might pause us
and come back in for a workshop i think
that might be the best way of handling
it rather than emailing it
um so when you're ready
uh if you can get that ready and then
i'll you do a sheer screen here and
we'll just i'll just pull up put us into
a workshop for a brief period
okay so john if we could just move to
8.3
which is
hecara road is that right
um
page 267 to 300 don
thank you i did sort out my two voices
thing is joanne sent me a quick message
saying i think you've still got your
live link on and i did so i had one
voice from the live link and one voice
from this so
uh apologies for sounding slightly um
you sounded you didn't sound any
different to us
[Laughter]
it was just what was going on your end
good job good that you're sorted
uh so hecarim road for those of you i'm
sure you've seen the maps this is the
new development just on the edge of
kaiapoi uh is
close to the um
close to the motorway uh it's been
progressed over a number of years in
terms of various consents being awarded
for this particular activity and very
just recently as in the last month or so
two further consents have been awarded
for this activity one being a land use
consent and one being a subdivision
consent
the subdivision consent envisages the
creation of
some new lots with new boundaries as
opposed to what was originally proposed
and as part of that envisages a road
stopping
and a road vesting
so the effect of this particular report
is to request that you that we approve
the road stopping
and also that we approve uh the
pda uh the private developer agreement
excuse me someone's phone's ringing in
the background circuit people that
aren't required on can they just mute
thank you sorry don
that was actually mine missed me
not only voices but we've got uh
the phones good work
and so we are asking for approval to
stop the road as well as approval for
the uh the pda
the pda effectively has a number of
sections in it
the main primary purpose originally for
the pda was to ensure that we had
uh agreement with the parties and
protection for the council
in that instance that should the road be
stopped but the road not be vested now
that's a very unlikely occurrence
because we'll be looking to do those two
things simultaneously
there are two potential paths as i think
the report spells out we could do it
through the public works act or the
local government act but either of those
pathways allows simultaneous stopping
investing
however as you're aware the stopping of
a road is a process that
has other parties involved in it and so
the protection here is that if the road
stopping did take place but the road
vesting didn't take place
there are some instruments allowed for
in the pda which allow the council
to carry out that vesting at some stage
in the future
so that is the primary purpose of the
pda but it also does
pick up on a little bit more detail in
terms of the intention of the
original resource consent to make sure
that all parties are very clear
on exactly how to interpret the
implementation of that resource consent
in addition to that
mr mia we also er this has been a very
fast-moving feast and there are two
other clauses which uh sheehan our
lawyer has drafted up for us
uh and they are really clauses for
information only they don't give effect
to
um to any material changes now your your
recommendation in front of you already
allows the adoption of this pda subject
to minor changes
and so i would put these in that
category of that effectively
what they do is they note that the
council is not putting in place
additional instruments to protect
against the road forming not taking
place so we may well get the road vested
but it may be some time or it may never
for instance get formed if for instance
the uh the other party goes bankrupt or
um or some other unforeseen event like
that
in that instance
the um
the the effect of the resource consent
cannot be given effect to
until the road is formed so even if it
were not uh formed immediately
nobody is going to build anything
further down there until such time as
that formation takes place so it's
really just acknowledging
that that risk is in fact there but is
acceptable because of the uh because of
the resource consent requirements
in addition there's a second clause
which says when that formation does take
place the parties agree that minor
boundary adjustments may be required to
take into account where the road has
actually ended up
and that says you'll be well aware when
we do form a road sometimes the batter
slopes go a little bit further than was
envisaged and it may well be that the
you know the tow edge of the batter or
the tow edge the drainage ends up
slightly outside the road reserve in
which case the parties agree that they
will work together
to
to give effect to that
now the
the other parties
the developers have been verbally spoken
to with that and they are happy with
those clauses being added in so from
their perspective they are comfortable
that they're just further explaining the
rationale for where we're at with us
so rather than speaking any further i
think i'll just hold the uh rob i'm not
sure if you've got anything further rob
hawthorne
otherwise i'm happy to take questions
rob you're on mute mate
sorry i'm just standing in for raymond
who did some of the earlier work on this
but um raymond as you may be aware is
moving on
to the city um so
standing in for him here
probably there are two salient things
and
the recommendations leave options open
for either progressing the road closure
via the pub public works act or the
local government act
and
on reviewing these there are merits to
both
under 1.16 in the summary
there's a small table there that
highlights the key elements of that
and the differences are largely around
potential timing
benefits
using the lga
and
the public consultation or the lack of
it
in
if we use that pwa by comparison with
the lga
there are risks associated with both
in terms of
reputational risks are
in relation to land information new
zealand and the public
in
using the public works act which allows
us greater speed but lacks the same
level of transparency that is
more common
there's a very small potential that you
could get a judicial review
where an aggrieved party chose to take
some action against
council and
the parties in progressing this
we believe that is very low
and there is still potential for
rejection by the minister
in relation to accepting the pwa as a
mechanism to progress this again we
think that's low
and we've talked through
these matters with the developers they
understand those risks
and are
keen to progress this development in as
timely a way as they can
and
their preference is to utilize the lga
approach
both approaches are certainly
reasonable and and have merit
but it's a little bit of a judgment call
between the two so instead of giving a
definitive answer in one direction or
other we thought we would allow some
debate around the council table as to
what your views were
but we have requested approval for the
ce and myself to progress that road
closing using one or the other so really
opening that up for your consideration
thank you um so questions i've got
council
atkinson thank you mr mayor just just
further to what um
uh what rob has just said
i'm struggling and my question is around
how is there a
uh risk even if it is low it's lower
than low given
that
the people who use the road are the
owners of the road
the development is actually being
developed
by
the developers who own the road
where are these objectional parties that
would stop
a road that isn't even used by anybody
except
the developers that are there now
and
the people who are going to develop
there
um who would have to come to that
agreement anyway
um why why are we even debating that
fact when
where is the danger from whom on a road
that is never used by anybody because
there's no one there
rob
uh right in response to that you're um
you've summarized that very well
and that's why we
consider that the lga in this instance
is
not an unreasonable
approach to take
however
the the norm in these cases is to go
through the um the pw uh through sorry
through the lga so i got those around
the wrong way um is to to go through the
lga it opens it up to wider scrutiny
uh and if we were to receive uh
objections from a party that was not
directly affected generally council
would
receive those objections or concerns
and give them relatively low weight in
making a decision
and the process normally follows that
there is some discussion and and not
negotiation but
working with that party to
explain things and
hopefully allow them to see that the
effect is
as minimal on them and that the
objection
is of question
if however they maintain their objection
even though they may not be directly
affected
the
the the discussion actually can
therefore be referred to the environment
court
so
a party can utilize this mechanism to
hold up a
development
by taking that action the environment
court in turn would consider
an objection that really had no impact
on that party
is as being objectionable and throw it
out and so there are some process steps
that you would go through
it is highly likely that if it were to
come back to council with a third party
objective
that council would reject that
so this really goes to
[Music]
the balance of probabilities
and in that respect
progressing this through the pwa
is highly likely to go through without
any um
uh concern or objection given that the
parties are
um are that are affected are in fact the
developers and owners promoting it uh
and so we would argue to lin's linds
and to the minister that
the the risk here to the public is
minimal
do you have another question there
council atkinson
no i just found that astonishing and
confusing because like i don't get it
i'm afraid i just okay it's only them
there's no one else okay um
perhaps a point for debate
um
uh
any other questions sorry i had
counsellor um sorry it's uh councillor
stuart thank you followed by councillor
redmond
thank you it's a bit tangential to this
but um i recall when this designing was
all was first put in that once volumes
got to
uh civil thousand five comes to mind
that there would be two traffic lights
on the corner with smith street
um
is this
altered in any way by what's going on or
when does that kick in
this requires uh those traffic lights to
be installed
as
part of the 224c
sign off for any further development uh
in there as as i mentioned there is now
uh an amended land use consent has been
applied for which gives a very specific
um
tenants or mentions types of tenants in
this area and their effects
uh
and so
before those land uses can be given an
effect to
uh that that road needs to be built and
those traffic lights installed
thank you
council redmond
uh thank you mr mayor um something i was
wondering about were the safety aspects
and roading aspects of the exit on smith
street near the motorway i checked that
with joanne so i just wondered if dom
might be able to provide the background
of discussions with nzta and so on that
have come up with
a solution uh for that aspect
certainly in terms of the roading design
uh this this development and the um the
solutions that have been put in place
has been has been fully um
discussed and uh and settled upon with
both internal council staff
and waka katahi nzta staff
uh wearing their road safety hat
and so all of the elements that you
would normally expect when any when any
development comes in our door
we we place a review over it from a road
safety perspective and a road asset
perspective we have carried out that
activity uh and in this instance of
course because it is so close to the
motorway uh the nzta were also required
to do that and they have also given
their approval to the final uh final
layout and the final solution that has
now been designed
the one element that is still to yet to
be resolved with nzta and i think this
has also been mentioned in the report is
that there still remains
uh link strips alongside the south side
of smith street which have not yet been
removed
and so again the pda mentions those
and indicates that
these roads
that are those link strips need to be
removed before those roads
well we the council needs assurance that
the link strips are either removed or
will be removed before we allow um
that road to be opened to the public we
have allowed the
or will be removed clause to be in there
because we recognize that these things
may take quite some time to work through
uh the internal nzta system uh and we
wouldn't like to hold up the whole
development waiting for that however we
would like assurance that nzta were
working uh towards that end goal but in
terms of the road safety you're quite
correct councillor redmond that this has
had full scrutiny of both council staff
and nzta staff
okay further questions we've got a
recommendation someone prepared to move
moved by council atkinson seconded by
councillor blacky
uh council atkinson
thank you mr mayor look this um this
needs to get go through we need to get
it underway as uh quickly as possible i
i think we we often try
to
mitigate no risk at all
and um
in anything we do that's impossible to
do
um
and and i'm an advocate for getting this
done as quickly as possible and
when you've got the parties that are
in this process are the affected party
of the process
then there's no no need to use any other
system than the quickest way that is
there if someone's going to object
they'll object anyway but i find it
pretty hard to believe that someone's
going to inject about object about an
internal road that's being done
for the developer and for well countdown
as it so happens as well as an agreed
party to this and us that it makes no
difference to us at all whether the road
is stopped and where it started because
there is nothing there it just makes
sense to get on and get it done the
quickest way possible and actually allow
people to get on with the developments
in which they're
in which they want to run so
i'm an advocate for um the fastest way
possible and yes there will be a little
risk in that but the risk is no higher
than taking the long road
so
i just want to see it go through as
quickly as possible i have no problem
with the recommendation it says you know
down to the property manager and the
chief executive so that's that's fine to
decide which way but i'm just advocating
for that quickest way possible it makes
absolute sense to me and let's not get
tied up in their own bureaucracy to uh
to stop something that's internal for
the developers
thank you council blackie do you wish to
speak thank you very briefly yes i think
it's a no-brainer i mean as the report
says we're providing an equivalent or
better access um which says it all
really i'll be like the other speakers
i'd be very surprised if there's any
objections in fact i'd go so fast to say
anyone objecting to this is just doing
doing so to be mischievous um we've
built in some flexibility the ce and rob
can can work work around the best scheme
um
no problem let's do it
further speakers
okay write a reply if you wish council
atkinson
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
with your hands country
i declare that kerry
thanks rob and don um don if you can
wait we will just
ali um i'll come back to you gerard
giroff are you
okay well did you wish to speak to it
yes
yes i wish to speak please um
just regarding the walking and cycling
uh report um just this morning the um
uh
nltp was released by wakakotahi
um and we have not received the walking
and cycling funding we were anticipating
in that um so just given
uh that and the um question over the
report
i actually do recommend that the report
is left
to lie on the table and
staff will bring a report back to the
next council meeting which will
cover off the question
uh regarding the program and also we'll
be able to
update the report to
include
where we
in terms of the funding so maybe jared
you could just advise you're withdrawing
the report at this point and come back
we don't need a procedural motion so
yeah i'm happy to accept that it doesn't
i think that's probably where the
direction was going to go if we didn't
get that so
8.2 at this point is withdrawn and we'll
come back to a further meeting so thank
you
um we now come to 8.4
um
so thanks uh
i see ali nearby thanks ali for being
present and kieran so that's vanessa
thompson and simon heart so that's pages
301-334
just as vanessa's coming on i just like
to commend you um vanessa i don't think
i've ever seen such a complete report
that's canvassed every option so well
done
we can't we can't see there we are yep
great right
simon
hello
so um that we're in your hands
so um good afternoon mayor and
councillors the purpose of this report
is to seek approval to conduct a
six-month trial of e-scooter share
services in the waimakariri district and
you'll note from the report um we're
proposing that flamingo scooters is the
partner for council in this
instance we're looking at a trial period
of six months from october to november
through to march april
there's no sort of operational cost for
council involved in this trial for mango
scooters all cover the operational cost
to run the troll in terms of the daily
activities and there's no additional
cost for council
we have had some pre-engagement with the
waimakariri access group youth council
and the age-friendly waimakariri there
had there were noted concerns and we've
tried to include include those concerns
in the geo fencing restrictions that
you'll see in the report
um so you'll note there's geo fencing
restrictions there
from items 4.3 to 4.4 and we've noted
there's no go no go zone areas um no
parking areas general speed restriction
zones and the like and that just
reflects concerns we've had from the
community those with that pre-engagement
uh staff
concerns of things that we wanted to try
and mitigate risks risks around
and um i'm sort of happy to take any
questions um but before i do i just want
to note the community boards have also
supported the trial and we've factored
in their feedback as well in those geo
fencing restrictions so happy to take
any questions
thanks vanessa any questions uh
councillor redmond
ah thank you vanessa a very
comprehensive report um
if i've read it correctly can williams
street between the bnz
and black walls be geofenced
we can we opted not to do that just
because that connects the north and
south of the kaiapoi town centre so we
um
the bnz sorry just correct me as the
north of the town over the bridge
south yeah oh south yes yeah we can um
geo fence areas like that if that was a
desire from council um we're just
mindful of geo-fencing where we need to
and in areas where we don't need to
because um
if we sort of restrict it too much it's
hard to get a really good sense of the
trial on how i would actually pan out in
the district so we're
hoping to keep most areas open um if
possible and just see how they go
because we can certainly admin things
through that six months if a particular
area is causing issues or whatever
would you agree there are
phil just sorry councillor edmund uh
simon you wish to eat today answer
uh thank you mr mia um just to add uh on
vanessa's points um this this set of
operating parameters
uh not only has been run through the
community boards who provided their
approval but also was worked in with the
town center implementation working group
who uh worked with us on on these
parameters
uh and and we had very robust discussion
about the geo-fencing areas and and we
did feel with the kai poi situation that
the connection between the northern part
of the town on the north side of the
river and the southern part of town
south part of the river was quite
important and the
access ways across and around those
areas were sufficient from which to
conduct those
uh those activities on the basis of
course that we can reduce speed and and
uh those sorts of things
council williams sir council redmond
sorry thank you uh vanessa would you
agree there are alternative routes to
get to the williams street bridge
uh
then we can certainly look there are
options there it's just that that's the
main one the main thoroughfare in terms
of people connecting the north and south
of town
finally um what guidance does nzta give
to speeds in
high use pedestrian areas
so at the you'll remember we did there
was an accessible streets regulatory
package that we submitted on last year
which
if that comes into effect
at some point i believe they're still
assessing it that would provide some
more controls in terms of speed
restrictions on footpaths they were
proposing to limit speed limits to 15k
is a general wash
um
so
at the moment i think there is there's
limited controls hence why that package
was put forward with some changes around
micro mobility inherents are adopted
across the country
uh so yeah there's there's limited
controls at the moment
in terms of
guidance from waikiki
okay so just on um geofence and
counselor williams uh sorry
counselor redmond sorry about me
counselor williams
um
i similarly had questions about that and
i was advised by
myself that had been considered by
both the um
working party and the community board so
uh the question of geo fencing and kybel
because that was a question we asked at
the when it came to workshop and
secondly can you just remind me is the
speed
are we planning to reduce the speeds in
kaiapoi town center
in that particular area
uh yeah so just on the williams street
bridge
between that that main sort of shopping
part of town we were looking at a 15k
speed limit in that particular area and
we thought that was an appropriate way
to to manage the risk initially um and i
do want to stress that we can um start
off these trials are just when we start
the trial we can assess things in the
first few weeks and and certainly change
things so if we find a particular area
these issues in the area we didn't
anticipate we can actually put
restrictions in pretty much straight
away um as long with the providers
should just resolve that
councillor atkinson and council award i
understand were part of that working
party did you wish to add would you like
to say something because you've been
part of this consideration would you
like to add anything council atkinson
well i think
that council redmond yeah i think that
i'll um i'll
keep that for the debate really because
i mean it's just to say that it's been
through a pretty pretty rigorous process
and some pretty hard debate
um from people sitting around the table
including the staff
questioning themselves on things that
they had put forward so it's been pretty
well canvassed before it got to this
point um you know about uh uh previous
actions of previous towns and so on and
so on so you can imagine where it's been
but i'll keep the rest for the debate uh
just
thank you councilwood
um i just want to say that it has been
through very rigorous discussion and
options and vanessa has put a lot of
time and effort into researching all the
possibilities in liaisoning with with
the the right ones and i think she's
done a superb job and really thank her
very much she's put so much effort into
it and i and time will tell and we'll
see how we go um but i think she's
covered all our options to give it the
best chance and um we'll be able to see
how things pan out during that six
months and all will be revealed
thank you
uh council redmond did you have another
question
uh yes mr mayor um
vanessa referring to the accessible
streets package um the information i had
was that nzta were considering a speed
limit of
10ks per hour is that something you've
considered
um i think accessible streets from my
understanding was 15k as a standard for
the streets however there would be an
option for councils to implement lower
speed standards if that was a
author a desire from a local council of
either 10 or 5. um however noting that
sort of 5k is probably not viable for
you know a commercial provider that
would be something they probably
wouldn't
be happy about um i for us i guess 15
noting that that was going to be the the
main standard and then in that package
that's what we've opted to
it's just to land on basically yeah i
think 10k is quite
quite slow it's quite um i mean simon
you might have some more comments around
that but uh 10k maybe we could certainly
look at it but it is a bit more
restrictive
what would you consider 15ks addresses
the concerns of grey power and the other
groups you consulted with
um i think it's uh it's an appropriate
response in terms of what's probably
done around the country in terms of
other cities how they've responded to
you know areas that might be perceived
as high in risk
uh 15k does appear to be a standard sort
of response so yeah i i would feel that
it's appropriate though we can certainly
if it's a desire of council to reduce
that we could certainly have a
conversation with the flamingo and see
how that
if how that sits with them
simon did you want to add something yes
thanks uh mr mayor um just just to
reiterate the point first i made a
little earlier that
i think it's important that when we
start the trial the parameters provide
the opportunity for people to use these
scooters in a way that they might feel
appropriate if we put too many
limitations on the parameters early up
we don't really get to assess the impact
of them as well as we might have and we
always reserve the right to negotiate
changed parameters midway through or
partway through the trial with the
provider so that if something is
becoming hazardous or a problem we can
limit the damage of that through the
limitation of the parameters as we go so
so whilst these parameters are being
recommended by staff
uh in the first instance uh we will be
monitoring this pretty pretty closely
with our with our colleagues and making
sure that parameters are adjusted if
indeed we find there are there are
issues
okay
um just a question i'm not sure who can
answer this one but um
is there a speed limit restriction on
mobility scooters in main streets
um i don't believe there is yeah exactly
there is
i think you're right minister i don't
think we have anything like that
that's reckless i need a question
i was indicating i'll move when you oh
okay all right so any further questions
so uh councilor atkinson is indicating
he'll move the seconded by councillor
award
council atkinson
thank you mr mayor
look it's actually with delight that i
uh uh uh move this this report in in the
trial for these scooters whilst i get
that grey power and axis groups have
issues
with
we'll call them vehicles they also have
issues with lines
color
and everything else that there is within
our community that is not to belittle
any one of those they are very real and
they are things that happen in our
community
unfortunately just like all of us we
have to learn to deal with these things
this is a step forward for our community
is it actually moving into the real
world we have a lot of students who get
around on these things in in
in
[Music]
cities in other areas and i welcome that
i think that that is fantastic that
people can get out get around and do
what they need to do as for kaiapoi's
main street we debated this quite long
and hard really about whether we should
uh
use kaikoura's main street it is a lot
wider than rangiora's main street
and the fact that 15 co restricted to 15
kilometers there's a bridge in the
middle of it so where do you stop you
put you you ride a scooter let's say
we'll go from the high school and you
have to stop at the main street walk
down the main street and then if you're
lucky there might be one halfway through
the day over the other side of the
bridge which means that you can jump on
a scooter and go all the way to
sovereign palms
doubt that's going to happen because the
five or six that are in the middle of
the main street that will have been used
during the day will be further out in
the suburbs somewhere so
the fact that you can actually ride
through the main street pick one up on
the outskirts and drive through the main
street to get to where you need to go
look will there be problems on footpaths
will there be problems around places all
trials have their issues
and we've been through the danger thing
i've heard people falling off them i've
heard you know they've broken their legs
and hit their heads and i'm sick and
tired of hearing that it doesn't matter
what you do if you climb a tree you can
fall out and break your arm
even at 60 years old i still climb the
odd tree with my grandson
it has never ever stopped me
and
we need to make sure that we move
forward into the modern world i'm
actually more than happy to put my face
to this when it goes to the community i
have no problem at all in in
promoting this and i hope that you will
all get on board with something that is
really progressive
and shows our community to be moving
forward
uh councilwood
thank you um yes and we have taken into
consideration uh rengura
and that
the safety at the main street um so
that's taken into consideration i think
kapoe is a little different so
i think um there's been lots of debate
uh lots of consideration and um just to
see how it goes and i'm sure that
vanessa and simon will be having um a
close look at how it starts to operate
and let's hope that there's no more
lockdowns and everybody can get out and
scoot around and have a wonderful time
in our community
council meetings
yeah i would just like to say this has
been a really well thought out report
you've weighed up the issues really well
and presented
all the options and come up with i think
what looks like a really good starting
point
it is a trial it can be modified as
needs be if we need to but i would like
to point out that according to my garmin
um
and all the walks and the cycling and
that i've been doing over um
over lockdown
your average brisk walking pace is 10
kilometers an hour that's brisk walking
so why would i take a scooter if i can't
actually
go any faster than i can walk anyhow
an average bike just you know
an average
not racing but bicycle
speed is is around 15k so we're not
actually putting anything any different
on the roads than what we've already got
going on now anyhow so
again
the fact that this is a trial and we can
modify as needs be once we get it
underway i think it's an exciting thing
for us
and i hope you'll support it
also redmond
ah thank you mr mia i would point out
that these
scooters are to go on the footpath not
on the road
and i've been influenced by the
submissions from grey power and others
which don't relate to the safety of the
scooter operator i think you take your
own chance if you're going to ride one
of these devices
but the risk of harm to pedestrians
and if you go online you can find
evidence of horrendous injuries that
pedestrians have suffered when hit by
scooters
it's a worldwide phenomena
the risk of harm could be mitigated to a
certain degree by the speed limit
and i note that
waka katahi
say that a nice
an e-scooter speed limit of 10k
is being considered
they had issues around how enforcement
would be carried out
and then say speed is a safety factor
for all forms of transport and
e-scooters are no exception
one of the key proposals under
consideration to improve e-scooter rider
safety and the safety of other footpath
users is establishing a maximum speed
limit for footpaths
with some ability for councils to adjust
this to suit local circumstances
so
i tend to think that 15k
when people are dawdling they're not
walking briskly when they're shopping in
and i'm talking about high pedestrian
access areas
i'm not talking about the passion bale
cycle way or those sort of areas but
where people are dawdling they're not
expecting to step out of a shop and be
taken out by an e-scooter now that's the
worst case scenario but it's possible
that it could happen
so um
i do have a concern
um of the speed limit if we're going to
have scooters in
high pedestrian shopping areas like the
main street of rangiora high street
although i think they're excluded from
there
uh but williams street in particular and
kyopoi so
um i'm not all in favor i'm in favour of
the trial but i'm not in favour of uh
the speed
thank you
um just speaking of the report by the
way wendy if you could tell ian uh flat
why to be nice thanks seems he was
making you know carfaster in the
background
um i'm going to support the trial the
the report um i think um vanessa you've
done a really good job can i acknowledge
the working party
um um who've um helped uh come to this
conclusion both council atkinson and
councillor ward
and also our boards that have been
involved really good to have had the
feedback from grey power and also the
access group because and our youth
council
particularly too because it does help us
um
understand what some of the concerns are
and where uh
in some of the pros and cons and so that
we those things can be considered and i
did
i i personally favor a geofence
in rengura town centre because of the
widths of the footpaths and i see it
myself and those of you who use the
footpath will understand that too
just the widths aren't as good as and as
as clear and
uh as they are in kaiapo and i would
have supported kaiboy if that had been a
concern from the
uh working party in the community board
but i think the 15k speed limit is as
reasonable and as is rightly indicated
this is a trial
we actually couldn't we can't prevent um
scooters from coming anyway so a trial
actually helps us
uh working with others that are going to
likely come in the future and they will
if it's popular i'm sure
others will look to come
in any event and some way of regulating
this and understanding how it works i
think makes a lot of sense
i have as simon and vanessa know um have
concerns around out the front of our
building is the parking location
um
but i have in discussing that but i know
that you're going to talk to them about
a particular area and marking that area
so it's clear
because we've spent a lot of money on
both
both in rangiora and kaiapoi
on the amenity uh where our buildings
are and i just don't want to see the
sort of these scooters thrown everywhere
an effect can be
in some signage that indicates where
they park and some clear instructions
and i understand that
the provider themselves they've actually
got to take a photograph of where it's
been placed and it's a condition of the
the money that the uh the charge
stopping and if they don't they they the
charge continues or they're penalized so
i'm comfortable there how this works i
also support this in the respect that
i've seen in auckland and other cities
around the world when travelled
just when it's not well managed here how
it ends up being a bit of a a problem in
auckland you know when you're up there
you can see them everywhere so um ann
just left everywhere too oh my dad not
that we can totally control that but a
trial helps us consider that so um
um
i do i certainly recognise the concerns
of grey power and the axis group but not
enough to prevent this from
from happening
but taking into account their concerns
the geo fencing the speed and the fact
that it's a six month trial i think
that's that's the basis in which i
support this and i know a lot of people
will enjoy using them so
um it'll be good to see how that goes so
just acknowledge the work of our staff
and that and thank you for um a really
comprehensive report
councilman
yes thank you very much for the report
again it um covered everything i think
we've canvassed a huge range of views in
the community and there's always going
to be those who are for and against but
i just like to emphasize some of the
reasons why it might be a benefit to us
as well um we've all had problems with
parking and it's becoming a
increasing issue
i've seen in other cities where people
actually park on the periphery and use
the scooters to go into the center and
as we become larger towns that's
actually going to become really
important and it facilitates
people going into the center and
shopping in different areas rather than
parking in one and then driving their
car to another one and so the trial is
going to tell us where people use it how
it's used uh what's going to happen i
had to go into work to um to get some
essential equipment um during the
lockdown i came out
of the corner of durham street and high
street and i was nearly run down by a
person on a mobility scooter they were
traveling very fast around the corner
and i didn't see them
when i came around the corner
if we are going to put any sort of speed
limits along our main street i really
suggest it needs to be unilateral needs
to cover every type of wheeled vehicle
that goes along our main street because
they are dangerous um and
if you get hit by a scooter of any sort
it's going to hurt so i really
what concerns me is i don't want to get
a double standard occurring here where
we penalize young people using scooters
and we allow other people who have
mobility scooters to travel at any speed
they need to have some regulation as
well if we're going to do that having
said that i'm sure council lebron will
say that it's almost impossible to
enforce it especially when they're young
people um
enforcement is really really difficult
and it comes down to the fact that we
have to encourage citizenship and people
being polite to each other i know that's
maybe a foreign concept in this day and
age but the idea is if you're on a
footpath you give way to other people it
doesn't matter if they're walking or on
a scooter or on a mobility scooter the
polite thing to do is give way and from
what i've seen of our residents most of
them are really really polite so i
actually think it's going to be a huge
benefit to have this added means of
transport if we can ever get a walking
and cycling path that links pegasus and
would end it'll be a godsend
um
so that's another thing that we need to
really put as a priority um linking some
of our areas that are further apart
south brook and rangiora it will
actually allow for people not to have to
make small journeys by car
and
that helps our environmental outcomes as
well so i really look forward to the
results of the trial i don't think it's
going to be all doom and gloom we've
seen and sell one that the results were
very positive and they had very little
trouble whatsoever there'll be some
minor tweaks needed and that happens in
any trail but i just would like to see
consistency uh looking at modern
solutions to our modern world improving
our environmental outcomes and improving
accessibility to our town centre for all
people so it's certainly in favor of
this trial and look forward to seeing
the results
thank you further speakers
my counselor williams
and followed by council duty
yeah no i support this trial um i have
got a bit of um i presume
designated area for example by the
council chambers there um was signed to
be paid for by the scooter company not
the um ratepayers
that's a question yes it is a question
for vanessa
um all right excuse me i'd have to just
follow
sorry follow up on that one um yeah i
would expect that they would pay for
that or if or if it's a really nominal
cost then we may be able to find some
budget out of it budget because this is
the recommendation and it said no cost
to the council for the whole lot so well
yeah the operation but there will be
some marketing costs for us anyway which
will be mainly for our online channels
very very small amount nominal but in
terms of actually operationally running
the trial and the day-to-day stuff that
that will be on for mango so what are we
looking some people in council say small
amounts is a large amount for other
people
so i guess like a couple hundred hundred
or something it'll be online channels
that sort of thing that that low yeah
yeah
okay
sorry uh sorry counselor dude you've had
me
thank you and yes i agree with
seeing this um go ahead i just think
this trial would be great and good luck
to everybody that that rides on because
i won't be but i mean i see you wouldn't
want anybody else not to to have that
enjoyment so i will be voting for it
we're the speakers
right reply accounts richardson
well look thank you for the support i i
think that this is going to be a great
thing interestingly um
uh i just had a quick look on um
on google while we were while we were
that was being debated and
in the last five years 10 people have
been killed on mobility scooters 19 have
been seriously injured and 70
pedestrians have reported near misses
from people with nobility scooters
now that's not going to be any different
you're compounding the problem by
putting scooters where um in in that
environment as well the council about it
is absolutely right if we're going to
have a look at speeds and start
criticizing people for doing things it
needs to be across the board
and
some of these very people
who are talking about access and being
able to be in and out of the criticisms
that we're getting
that people shouldn't use scooters
and
i i don't think myself that that is fair
the footpath situation these can be
written on the road as well
they are not just for the footpath i can
suggest to you that uh i would be very
surprised if most people would be riding
um the scooters through the main street
of kaiokoi on the footpath there's a
there's a lane there that they can use
they go at 15 k's
my understanding is that the cars are in
the middle of guyapo go anywhere from 17
kilometers to an hour to 22. this could
be a very good way of actually keeping
the cars back to 15 kilometers an hour
by then riding through there so i think
that could actually be a bonus we need
to turn that round and put it on its
head
and it may be after the trial that we
actually are asking people to put these
in the main street in that particular
area down the road so that that can
happen that you can actually keep that
to a safer
safer speed
um
and i think that's the realities of foot
powers wherever you are if it's
congested with people they won't write
down them
15ks i don't know if any of you well i
know most of you ridden push bikes and i
know most of you have done a lot of
things around things but trying to ride
a scooter at 10 k's or less is actually
a lot harder and more dangerous than it
is at 15 k's an hour the slower you go
the harder it is to keep your balance so
you actually need to be
making sure that you're maintaining a
speed so that you can um
so that you can keep your momentums up
parking i think um
again councilman it's absolutely right
people who will pick them up
and
pack the car further out to catch the
scooter in in fact
mia sam broughton myself
attended the um
michael's um
uh
police
awards ceremony uh two years ago and we
both from ecan because we were running
short of time uh went on scooter from
ecan to saint michael's church
and i can tell you it was not only
pleasurable but so simple to do
and the people who are who fear these
things are the people who don't use them
we must remember that years ago when the
horse got a cart behind it all people
did was fear the horse and cart and the
people were going to die through these
monstrosities of things
thank you
thank you council reckons and i'll put
the recommendation all those in favor
please say aye
contrary
i declare that kerry thanks vanessa and
thanks simon good work thank you
all right so um now uh it's look i'm
going to keep going um
until
we finish the
open agenda uh and then we'll break for
afternoon tea at that point so
um i'm hoping we'd be breaking about 3
30 if that gives an indication so
but um obviously it'll be non-debate um
so um
uh item 9.1 don
335-345 which is the capital works
program update
thank you mr mayor um this hopefully
will be quite quick the only reason this
is really on here referred from the
audit and risk committee meeting which
considers the quarterly report is
because of the
amendment required to tidy up the
budgets which was discussed by audit and
risk but needs to be approved by the
council so you'll note here that
there was an arithmetic error in an
earlier report requesting
money to be shuffled around that money
is now being
spent accordingly
and
this is really just giving effect to
what has already happened uh there were
some questions that order and risk and
they may uh appear here again and i'm
happy to answer any questions that do
come up
thank you questions
so we've got a recommendation sorry
counselor becky i can frame it as a
question don um
page 342 item 10 um 10.3 you need to put
a comma after after the word cass it
reads north cass community studios which
is meaningless it should be north cass
comma
and community studios and courtney
espina the
reference to north cast not being a
completed project is a very minor main
power electrical connection that hasn't
been done we'll just put a comma after
the word cast please
okay and answer your question yes i will
action council award you're going to
move is there any other questions
it's a move council awards seconded by
councillor mailings i can see her
enthusiastic putting up her hand
cast award
you should speak
no that's fine it's just a tidy up and
um thanks don and uh yes no i don't have
anything further to say
all right any further speakers
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye aye
contrary to clear that carrot thanks don
9.2 is actually just for information so
there's no action required
um and anyway um
we just discussed the other matter just
before so nine point three is heritage
in the hingakai so that's
uh duncan roxburgh duncan's coming into
the waiting coming out of the waiting
room and then to the
not going to say the fire but the
meeting
hi duncan
hello
how are you
thank you we haven't got you um visually
but um that's no problem so oh we do now
great to see you duncan
um so
your report pages 375 to 417 is there
anything you wish to highlight
uh yes
um
the purpose of the report um like it was
really just to establish those
co-governance arrangements for the
heritage of muhingakai area
so we have had a number of briefings
with mahitai committee
the last one been in april we were
instructed to to go away um
we spoke to the general manager of
the trust who took a report to them in
july
and then subsequently we came back to
mahita committee
in
august with this report
perhaps if i may just quickly touch on
some of the key discussion or
possible
resolutions or changes made from that
meeting um
are they
are they contained within the
recommendations now uh yeah so they are
in the uh recommendations in your agenda
and the summary yeah and the summary
agenda yes so the main one was really
around recommendation c
there was a request to
remove reference to
um for makarini rupini who's the
representative from the runanga on the
joint working group
just remove reference to environment
canterbury and his
title from environment canterbury
because he is there
as a representative from the runanga
and not ecan
and
based on some of the discussion was had
we also um added the word there or
alternate representative as well
um
yeah and so just regarding timing there
was some discussion around timing um and
the next steps so
the next steps would be that assuming
all goes through today
we would stand up the the joint working
group um
as soon as possible and then come back
to council
with the report um and hopefully that
will be to the next council meeting
with some proposed
lease
a proposed draft lease and any
amendments as needed to the
trust deed
there was a question asked around the
likely
term of the lease um suggestion is that
that would probably be
um
starting with a term of 30 years perhaps
and that was really just to
give good um
certainty
to the trust uh you know who are going
to take on the
uh co-governance and management of this
um
reserve uh they need that long-term
certainty before they could commit to
that so
happy to answer any questions
thanks duncan any questions
okay i've got a recommendation the
moving counselor blackie
seconded my
second counselor atkinson counselor
becky do you wish to see yeah yeah very
briefly thank you duncan good report um
chika haka have
been over this last week and ticked it
all off they're happy there's one
there's one mention in there of the
huria name for the mahangakai area with
some um reference to it not being
finalized that now has been finalized
and put to bed um tamari has um has
ruled that it will be called the huria
mahangakai reserve
i think happy to recommend the um
recommendations
thank you council atkinson
for the speakers
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye all right contrary
to clear that carry duncan um thanks for
all your work there's been a lot of work
going on to this and been a series of
briefings so colleagues are well over it
so lack of debates not showing a lack of
support it's just that we've had a lot
of conversation over the time so thank
you and probably pleasure to join this
afternoon
it's nice to have you here with us thank
you
all right um thank you we come now to um
item 10.1
which is the well-being health and
safety report that's mr harlan our chief
executive
um thank you
don um i mean the key point here is that
there have been any
notifiable events health and safety in
the last month which is a good result
and they were deemed to be compliant
with our obligations we do have a new
manager in this area
and
she's looking to improve our
annual safety plan our well-being
strategy uh refreshing those documents
which is always a good thing
this group has also provided good
support to the internal team
giving advice to the organization around
covert
and they've had a weekly
lockdown well-being news with emails and
tips
linking to various websites on how
people can you know basically keep
themselves safe mentally and physically
during
the covered environment so
those are probably the key points
mr mia's happy to take questions
thanks john many questions of jim
no questions someone prepared to move
moved council awards seconded by council
of duty council what do you wish to
speak
i know that's just a great report and
and
are really good at just no issues with
with a large organisation so well done
okay thank you council duty
thank you yes no good report it was
interesting that um
a comment was made to me that
someone had from council had run up and
checked on this particular lady that
lives on her own and she was very
grateful so i don't know who did it but
it was
it was well well appreciated
okay
oh and this is any further speakers i'll
put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary
declare it carried thank you so we come
to committee minutes for information
this is a recommendation 11.1 to 11.5 be
received for information
moved to council duty seconded by
council award
uh just before i put that is there any
questions on any of those committee
minutes there
no
so put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carried
then we've got community board minutes
for information so it's 12.1 to 12.5 be
received councilbar that's going to move
that i can see it putting a hand up
seconded by
councillor duty
any questions on any of those reports
do you wish to say anything counts about
it yep
i just wanted to ask a question about
the rangiora parking strategy that was
raised again at the board meeting and
just wondering when we're going to have
some feedback on that i appreciate it's
probably all been delayed with covered
but um it's becoming quite urgent
because we're getting a lot of piecemeal
parking requests coming to the board
um not sure on the answer to that
particularly but perhaps tia you could
just take a note of that
it could be a matter that could come
back but we are next week we've got a
joint meeting with the board on
a matter that's to do with the parking
building so that's a briefing coming to
council next week so
tier if you could take note of that
uh and feed that through to joanne and
perhaps simon
uh hart around that matter i will do sir
so jim did you want to say something
sorry i just saw you've gone off mute
yeah no it was just to say what you said
donald that we could probably pick it up
next week at that briefing okay
all right
okay so with that um any
so i'll put the recommendation all those
in favor please say aye contrary
clear that carried i've got no reports
for information
no correspondence
so 15 is my diary there's a
recommendation there somewhere prepared
to move that move to counselor atkinson
seconded council award
um
do you wish to speak
no
any questions i'll put that all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carried
so we come to portfolio updates and if
we could try and keep it
brief then we'll get to afternoon teas
just briefly um under ewe relationships
a lot of work's gone in
uh both staff and and certainly from
maine and the other colleagues who are
part of mahitahi to
get the kayang and the honga provisions
in the district plan
really proud of where we've got to on
that it's uh it's been a huge piece of
work and
um acknowledged the work of our staff
and also
um both tamale and tanya
that's
you know recognizing 170 years has gone
by since we should have done the right
thing there's been some progressive
steps but this will be one of the most
progressive that we have actually having
an enshrined
in our district plan still work to be
done as we know and still
things to resolve but it's part of a
good relationship so i think the
relationship at a uh ewe level is really
strong and really pleased where uh
that's it and um appreciate all the
support of the members that helped
contribute to that including our staff
uh any questions
okay um so greater christchurch
partnership do needle or nikki do you
want to leave that to start with
i actually wasn't there i was absent
from the last one
so unfortunately um i had a hospital
appointment so unfortunately i wasn't
there
so
i'll stick out of this one
nick did you want to say anything
so just but the the main one we had a
briefing on
council a couple of weeks back which was
to do with the urban growth partnership
and then there was some updates on the
um great greater christchurch 2050
project and also
to do with the passenger transport
matters which
had been workshopped and was talking
about uh
potential fees and fee structures uh
there was a workshop there so it was
quite interesting actually but that'll
all come back to council and due course
but i think the other main matters we
discussed a if i missed anything jim or
nikki
okay
no well other than
the christchurch 2050 and the spatial
planning work is getting a bit more of
an impetus
particularly the spatial planning work
with the the two ministers who were down
so
i guess the biggest worry i've got is
that we do that work
then in three or four years time
under the new rma whatever it's called
to be the spatial planning act and we'll
be doing another one again so
you know it's it's going to keep our
planning people busy for a while yet
okay thanks jim
um kennedy water management strategy
council stuart
thank you
just one one item
and you may have seen something this
morning but um
ecan has
reported back on the canterbury water
management strategy after 10 years and i
must say i'm incredibly disappointed
with what has come out of the 10 planks
of that strategy
not one has been met
two have been partially met but the rest
of them
not met at all
so um i mean and this
the planks are environmental limits not
met
ecosystem health and bio diversity not
met the only two um things like
drinking water standards not met
um
water use efficiency not met
um improving um
[Music]
natural and original economic uh
prospects added value to use of water
not met
so
um
seriously um i would like this to be put
to the um category mural forum about
where where does this strategy go to
um now it obviously needs a review in my
my view and
um i'll send you um a link to the report
which is environment canterbury's own
report on its own strategy
after this meeting and also
there's a staff article which summarises
um and gets some comment about it
but after 10 years
to have not won of the major planks of
the strategy met in any shape or form
and two
only
two partially met as the only results of
it
is incredibly disappointing
so to me as i said i think it should be
on the agenda for the mural forum about
what happens um going forward here
any questions
thanks sandra any questions of sandra i
agree with you
i'd like to see a copy of the report
uh and also the staff article satire if
you could get
it's online i've got it here i'll send
it to you it'd be helpful but i think it
would be very useful jim if we can get
one of our policy staff to um have a
look at that and provide a response to
us as well
um but i would certainly be i'll have a
read of it and in terms of the
conversation at mural forum happy to
consider that so thanks sandra but i
would be very useful to have our policy
team put their eyes over and provide
some advice back to us um so tia and jim
if you can hear if you can prompt jim to
um
around that that would be helpful i
choose life mr mayor but i will do it
what's it sorry i choose life but i will
do it
he's a very nice man
[Laughter]
unless you know something i don't anyway
i'll ask you offline
all right thank you um international
relationships um
uh not much tool mr mia just just to say
that we have had a letter from inchi um
inquiring about their status under
lockdown and wishing us all well and uh
it won't last too long and that uh we're
all still alive so i will make sure that
we uh we reply to that in the
appropriate manner
thank you
questions of nibble
uh we've regen council becky yes i've
very little to report mr mayor uh the
little business consortium that are
interested in putting a flotel on the
river came back to us this morning now
we're sort of out of lockdown saying can
we move this with all expediency please
similarly um
uh templeton group this morning came
back to us and said with uh pegasus lake
problem that they're getting making some
serious progress for once and with the
aeration
option there they're envisaging and are
talking to ecan about consents for that
and that's about all i've got
thank you um questions of council blacky
all right so uh climate change
sustainability council meetings
i apologize before i was losing my my
headphones um
yeah so before i lock down i attended
the in addition to the tcp which you
covered nicely um attended the um
christchurch city council's i'm working
um like coastal houses working group and
um yeah basically they are now at the
point where they've got their draft at
coastal adaptation framework ready to go
out to consultation shortly and um they
are test driving an online portal which
um for coastal hazards assessment which
people can like put in an address or an
area and select variables like you know
scalable right scenario or the year or
whatever and and it'll actually um um
show them the effects on on their
properties or that area
um which is quite interesting it'll be
um quite a good interactive thing for
people and that would be good for us to
have something like that here
and on the 16th we
had the
the sustainability strategy steering
group meeting and we had
greg from
tktp and heather from enc
and
which is really good having them there
both of them are looking to
purchase
electric vehicles for their fleets
and um
enc of course they're like their
business awards are now postponed but
that's intended to be a zero waste event
using all local produce
and all locally yeah all locally grown
and produced
food which would be quite neat if they
actually really get to hold that at some
point and uh
takohaka with hukai taught a trust has
students out mapping wetlands and
with a view to gradual replacement of
their pines in the future and
they want to
grow and harvest
natives like totora
in the future just quite cool they've
got a new visitor center building
pending and
that's probably that for them and the
staff travel survey about 40 percent of
the staff have have responded saying
that they'd be interested
in investigating a rideshare scheme as a
priority so um yeah we'll see where they
get with that
and just behind the scenes basically
with the
climate change sustainability response
the national policy is still in a state
of flux really with the ministry for
environment um guidance due this month
and we're just basically waiting on that
there's a few things we can do but by
and large we're in a holding pattern
like everybody and everything else so
that's it for me
thank you any questions of council
mailings
uh business promotion and town centre's
council board
um just a few things um of course the
business awards have been postponed
possibly to november the 17th or 18th
but will be advised soon i think that's
going to be during the week um
another thing that's been postponed is
the waimakariri district chapter 86
squadron
chapter day
which is
a new date which is coming
coming possibly october the 31st subject
to mayor dan
um
fitting in with with with that um
and we had a catch up with the joint
promotions association
and
i had i got to meet
danny and peter riley the new contacts
for oxford promotions they're really
lovely couple and i'm sure that they
will contribute greatly to the smooth
running and the positiveness for oxford
promotions going forward so it's nice to
meet them
albert on zoom
and um uh enterprise north canterbury
checking in with heather
um she she said that um with this
lockdown that we've just had that most
businesses haven't needed support this
time
there was only quite a few inquiries of
it that needed assistance so i think
they've done a really good job of
supporting people last time and most
people
knew what what avenues they could take
to to get support to get through this
lockdown so she was quite happy that it
wasn't too busy in that and that um
in that avenue so that's that's that's
really all from me
thank you thanks joan any questions
uh by the way um just on that point i
have said that the 31st is fine with me
um
so um
it's for number 88 squadron that's the
street parade um
but that'll be dependent on obviously
where we're at levels etc but it's a wee
way away so hopefully
we'll be okay
all right so um with that i've got no
questions no urgent general business
so
we've got a recommendation there about
moving to public excluded so as someone
prepared to move the recommendation
there
moved by council blacky seconded by
councillor duty
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye